welcome to another episode of not too
deep this one is very special this was
our live episode at SF Sketchfest with
the one the only the queen goddess of
digital content someone that I've looked
up to for years Felicia Day we also want
to thank twitch for the footage from the
actual live recording of the podcast
this was so fun
Felicia's a mom a mogul and it's just
got the same hang-ups about her hair
that I do so enjoy this live episode
from SF Sketchfest of not too deep with
Felicia Day this episode of not too deep
is brought to you by the OkCupid dating
app OkCupid dating app is the only
dating app that finds you someone based
on who you are and what you're into
answer fun questions and meet someone
who shares your deep love or loathing of
pineapple on pizza or commiserate on
your views of the current state of the
world the OkCupid dating app has awesome
people like you who are into what you're
into you download the free OkCupid
dating app today
[Music]
hello good evening what time is it okay
hi guys thank you so much for being here
this is gonna be very very fun you're at
the Streamy award winning podcast not
too deep
yeah that's important in specific and
we're really proud of it
I'm going to be very upfront with you I
am aggressively hungover today so it's a
nothing it's different this episode
basically so yeah this is a struggle bus
today for all of us and I'm glad that
you guys are here to enjoy it because
it's a very very very fun episode of the
Streamy award winning podcast not too
deep also we're gonna do things a little
bit differently here we're gonna talk to
our absolutely fabulous guests and then
we want you guys that are actually in
house with us today do you participate
so if you have any questions stewing
brewing in your brain continue them on
the slow cooker until later on and we
will get to those so stew and brew okay
I'm very thrilled to bring out someone
that I've been insanely inspired by in
my journey in the digital world in my
journey and becoming an independent
woman and just in general someone that I
think makes I got out of breath reading
her Wikipedia page like an hour ago and
I was just reading it in my head and I
got very tired in my hotel room I don't
know I mean it's always kind of [ __ ]
to give her a bunch of different like
slash slash slash slash slash but she's
an American actress voice actress a
singer a writer a web series creator and
one of her greatest accolades of all
time that I only learned today and I
cannot wait to get into this is that she
is one of the stars of bring it on again
please give a round of applause for
today is not too deep guests Felicia Day
[Applause]
[Music]
welcome welcome
why it's on your Wikipedia I might ask
my wikipedia says that I'm a pole vault
medalist and that I did the Miss New
Jersey pageant so if I get that asked
you get that asked are you really a poll
watcher at one time I did it and I was
the only girl competing so technically I
won so you got like a sexist medal for
big time but I took advantage of it I
looked around I said there's no other
females I think I could throw my legs up
over that happens and now it's on my
Wikipedia page so let's get to the core
of where you've built your brand bring
it on again
okay listen that was such a long time
first of all I think that was my first
real job as an actor and when I look
back at my fashion uh-huh some of my
worst I had like those aggressive like
they were late 90s that I just I guess
was bled over to the early 2000s because
I just kept them the chunky you know
like you're a redhead but then you think
this looks natural let's do an inch
stripe of platinum and then it had like
that unfortunate slip out that was like
this the that yeah I was like the Paige
Davis Trading Spaces because I was 20
years younger than her clearly I know
that's who I needed an MLA style icon
Paige Davis from TLC's Trading Places I
mean I always thought she was so peppy
but I see now the hate in her eye yeah
you watch every right yeah the going
through it movements yeah just going
through it like this isn't it this I was
a musical theater major and this is also
okay I want to get into so much stuff
and I'm sure you've been asked a billion
times about billion things because your
career has a billion different just like
notches to it but one of the fun facts
that we found was that your mom drove
you to Ohio and surprise you with a
Mouseketeers audition is that true
true it's from my box I mean I did write
truth in my biography Oh see hmm I did
teach me your ways no my mom is a real
kooky she's a kooky lady okay
she's memorable she would spend an hour
adjective for someone you're memorable
she definitely makes you depression like
if I ever run into anybody it's like Oh
how's your mom I'm like I didn't know
you know my mom but thanks
she's got a person who will spend an
hour at like the Clinique counter
learning like counseling the woman who
works there on her relationship you know
and then you'd never see him again oh so
I'm really glad you invested that time
mom but my brother and I are just
sitting here yes that was my childhood
she really I mean she had the best of
intentions but I don't think she had the
practical application of preparing a
child okay so she would just take me
places like we're gonna go on auditions
for the American Ballet Theatre I'm like
I just started doing ballet mom I don't
think you're setting me up for success
right now how did she get you into these
auditions she just register like
children can be just cattle doubt I mean
you can audition for anything oh I guess
if you just show a show up there like
you're on the list I get I don't know
it's kind of like you get past the
bouncer to get your child into some
weird camp that you never actually sewn
into that's true yeah so how did the
audition go it was not good and that's
why I to this day have an anxiety
disorder around auditions well okay mom
your newest I think profession is your
mother now I mean I don't get paid for
it so I don't know if it's a profession
since I haven't done it yeah until I can
get just non-stop brand deals out of
like something shooting on my cooter I'm
not doing it I mean you could be that
woman who's like shows like the same
like emotional connection to the thing
that they made yeah yeah you do that or
you could just be I'm just using this as
a way to reinvigorate my brand like
you're a mommy blogger now just like
exploit exploit exploit uh a scummy
mommy vlogger I don't think that genre
exists
I could pave the way no there are some
scummy mommy black
did you see there's one woman who was
like she put a picture of one of her
children online and it was his birthday
or something and she's like I don't
forget the kid's name it's like a little
Logan I love you so much and it breaks
my heart that you get a fewer likes than
my other two babies you're just this is
for real this is for real and it's like
she goes on it so you know what does
Instagram post where it's like a blog
post with just under a child smiling
face we're like I see the tournament and
your eyes Logan I'm so sorry oh no she
was like basically like frustrated that
she that he didn't get enough likes and
that one day he would be demoralized by
the fact that he got less social
engagement than his siblings this is a
real authentic so there are scum out
there who could she scummy couch yes I
that's why I only post like two pictures
of my baby a year because I'm like I
would love to make money off of you I
see the temptation I would love to have
free things just blood and like oh he
got a new pair of shoes but man you know
you know the stuff that you could to get
sent from Jessica Alba she's not sent me
anything
well I'll DM her after this thank you
but what I was curious about because we
talked about this a little bit before
what are your parameters in terms of
like how much you posts of your kid like
you are protective I mean I you know
it's it's not right for me to make her a
vehicle of my own business in a sense so
I don't want to exploit her but then I
really I don't it's it's a really hard
balance because yeah I most of my day is
- I mean I do have a nanny who takes
care of her because I do work during the
day yeah but I'm around her I make sure
to be around her so but in toto I don't
I can't talk about the six hours of like
fallout I played anymore because that's
child neglect okay we just definitely
talked about it
those are the good old days I mean so
like there's not like if I don't talk
about it at all like I don't know if I
have anything left of myself right right
then so I I kind of like and I want to
share it because it's like amazing
seeing a person like I can mold this
person and yeah oh my god I'm molding
this person like but um so it's it's
it's kind of a balance so was like a
continuous learning curve always always
and it's just now that she's becoming a
real person I'm even more like
protective like I don't want to use her
but then I don't you know I'm not like
crazy about it so I post a couple
pictures of her year and I as she gets
older I don't know if I'll do that
anymore because I don't want her to be
recognizable because I think when we
start to see ourselves outside of
ourselves for the other people's eyes
then you start to get stunted by their
perception of you because nobody's gonna
see you the way that you see yourself
and your say and I think that a hundred
percent makes sense resonates so hard
because it's not even about like
nowadays a like a parent putting a kid
in front of a screen it's like a kid
will be on social media which will also
have that affect on them regardless so
do as much as you can now to keep them
pure exactly good
I'm trying she will grow up to be an
evil side I mean evil scientist would be
cool that'd be actually thing right I
would be cool with her I plague I mean
do you got a rifle plague but like a
plague that shoot you want her to grow
up to be a plague no I but like not a
deadly plague I don't want her to murder
people but maybe just like a weight loss
plague okay that's basically just we can
continue brainstorming this future and
then I let her bloom is there any career
path that you want her to stay away from
like if she got into entertainment if
she got into gaming if she got into
comedy like are there avenues that
you're like I'll let her do it but I
also feel a little uncomfortable with it
I mean Republican yep
I was literally thinking that the other
day like I really just want to be I
think my job is to allow her to grow up
and find herself and not over the
overdue unduly influenced her but of
course I'm gonna expose her to board
games way more than any other normal
parent would be if she decides she likes
sports I'll be disappointed and I won't
be able to hide that like I feel like my
job is to allow her to flourish and
encourage her and enable her exposure to
everything and then reinforce what she
likes and I healthiest perspective yeah
I hope I mean listen I'm gonna screw up
somehow but I can at least have you guys
her to hear first so yeah the best of
intentions we'll see what happens
attention so I feel like I would be
disappointed if she became okay I mean
both those two are bottom of the barrel
[Laughter]
boundaries
let her know the disappointments early
on okay let's talk about your entire
career Oh dig in I mean we cut we didn't
even cover bring it on again I mean that
was just seminal piece of entertainment
where I played a cheerleader who I mean
I'm a ballerina who was healed by chair
you know yeah I mean I only saw bring it
on I don't even see bring it on again oh
oh so you missed the majesty that was
the direct-to-dvd sequel I don't want
any spoilers all I remember is that I
was sexually harassed by the director Oh
in a bad and well okay I don't want to
get into it because that probably I
might expose me to a lawsuit yeah so
let's not talk about it more all right
straight-to-dvd let's talk about well
one we're on twitch right now oh that's
right we're hanging hi twitch who hates
me sure do
oh yeah okay so this is a question I
have for you you you stream on Twitch
it's something I'm not super familiar
with but you're also very well-versed in
a lot of social media platforms and if
you had to assign different social media
platforms different personality types
what would you say like twitch and
Instagram and Twitter oh so you want me
to do all of them
I'm just a couple I mean quitter Oh God
Instagram it's just it's yeah boy
Twitter he's like a person that like no
offense Florida but like it's like
Florida you think it's Florida Florida
is so bad
well Twitter I mean Twitter to me is
like Florida it like has some cool
moments but then it [ __ ] up and then
you're like come on what now you get
toxic and you're doing bath salts but
then you got Disney so okay Jimmy
Florida it's totally like vine it's just
dead and it was always not a good place
to go and now that it's dead it just
still lives on somehow okay fair very
fair
I mean twitch is like like a sort of
aggressive teenager who who wears like a
sneer but then if you were nice to him
they might cry later
oh yeah that pretends they don't want
like a sensitive attention but they
secretly want to be acknowledged yeah
it's taken care of
exactly that's my aesthetic that's your
[ __ ] a weakness yeah I also dress like
I think most of twitch users probably
dress why would you switch Chron this
year and you know you wouldn't fit in
you'd fit in you would fit in I would
fit in hell yeah yeah you would cool
I'll bring my rollerblades how would you
describe Instagram like what is your in
terms of social media we talked a little
about this before too like I feel a huge
sense of burnout recently in a lot of my
like friends I have felt a really sent a
big sense of burnout just because we've
been doing internet for like 10 plus
years
do you have platforms that you prefer
over others or do you kind of feel like
I'm just doing it because it's part of
my job I mean I don't do that anymore
like my job is not digital anymore I'm
like I'm working I mean I work as an
actor and I'm working as a writer a lot
in Hollywood and the things that I'm
working on are mostly writing and acting
and producing yeah you know so I don't
you know I'm not fully in the digital
media space as much as I used to be
which I kind of miss and that's why I
stream which weekly on Twitch I started
five years ago just for fun and then
because I loved it so much I had my
companies start a twitch channel geek
and sundry and it became a real passion
of mine and
when a couple of years ago I just kind
of I'm not there anymore at the company
but I still do it because that's my sort
of life linked to the you know that and
my I do a little podcast called
felicitations which is me just like in
my office at night alone did you do that
you you popped every other way yourself
but I'm like what yeah I just cut myself
okay I mean I talk out loud at my dog
all day that's basically what I do very
friend the internet literally will
listen to whatever I say it's great so
those are my two sort of linked life
links I mean I love Twitter
I just am a writer and I admire funny
writing and I love to get him raised
about politics which I'm always like
ranged retweeting and then I'm like stop
and look at my feet I'm like oh you're
awful so just do a funny thing about a
dog but and then just break it up you
know yeah um Instagram is harder for me
because I feel like the people I follow
really like I'm not certain but I
believe most people have a professional
photographer in their house I'd like at
it five days out of the week like I
don't understand how they always have so
many different looks and outfits and
looks so perfect yep and I was never
that person I was always the person that
had salad in their teeth no matter how
many people worked on them you know like
I never feel like I'm actually
presentable
I went to dry bar and all I can do is
smell the stink of dry you branded me
dry bar it's like a cologne from a guy
and they you see me like you hug them
and it's just on you ya weeks
yeah that's why I'm wearing a hat
because I'm just full scum up here
there's let me I'll just rub some dry
yeah I mean it feels like so one
question that we had to come in from
Twitter a lot was what do you prefer or
what feels more natural to you writing
versus acting is there one just going
kind of like they switch off you're in
there depending on what you work I love
acting I don't do it as much as I would
like but then of course if I did more of
it I probably wouldn't like it anyway
I'm just kind of the one of those people
that can't folk I don't like just doing
one thing I get very bored easily and so
I'm in the middle of two writing
projects that are like six-month
projects and like I'm week two and I'm
like it's too long
like delay that gratification was like
ruined me by the Internet so I think
that oh god I've been working for
sending two months it's like five
eternities I think my child is twenty
five now like that's what it feels like
so I mean I like having written but the
process of writing is the more I've
forced myself to do it the more it
becomes sort of a habit which makes it
easier but like getting into it is like
oh my god it's so hard um I mean I like
acting because somebody else does my
hair like it is literally half my life
it's just as is worth doing my hair for
it no I'm gonna pass yep like I'm not
even kidding like it's yeah my morning
mantra is it worth making myself look
less gross today that's what I can't
Instagram I literally we were talking
about this I will agree to go to events
just so I will force myself to look
presentable so I have something on my
feet this is like not supposed to be
what life ended up being but it's just
here we are this episode of not too deep
is brought to you by Mark Arie do you
have a bunch of stuff lying around the
house that you just don't use a pair of
jeans that was only worn once an old
phone hiding in a drawer somewhere
Macari is an app you can use to sell all
this stuff they make it fast and easy to
sell almost anything simply take a few
pics of your stuff add a description and
boom your item is listed once it's sold
Macari emails you a shipping label and
you just send it off
no meetups or strangers no hassles with
Macari you can sell everything from
fashion to electronics and toys to
Sporting Goods over 100,000 items get
listed on Mercury every day earn an
extra few dollars and clear up valuable
space in your home with Macari the app
has over 300,000 reviews on the App
Store with an average 4.8 star rating so
why not give it a try don't let that
stuff you don't use go to waste
sell it ship it and get paid with
Mercury you can find mercury on the App
Store or on Macari calm em er see a RI
Macari the selling at zola is
reinventing the wedding planning and
registry experience to make the
happiest moment in couples lives even
happier combining compassionate customer
service with modern tools and technology
all in the service of love Zola is the
easiest way to plan your wedding and
register with free wedding websites your
dream wedding registry affordable save
the date and invitations and easy to use
planning tools start with a free wedding
website it takes just minutes to set up
and you can choose from over 100
beautiful designs that fit any style and
every type of wedding put your Zola
registry on your wedding website so
guests can get all the details they need
and buy your wedding gift in one
convenient place the Zola store has the
widest selection of gifts at all
different price points from over 500
brands there's something for every guest
to give and I've had friends that have
used this it is a one-stop shop it makes
what is a stressful experience planning
your wedding that much easier so start
your free wedding website and get $50
off your registry on Zola go to Zola
comm / grace that Zola's eol a.com slash
grace to get $50 off your registry today
ok
I remember when you started geek &
sundry I was so inspired by that because
I was kind of still figuring out my like
navigating YouTube and figuring out how
my like independence on that platform
worked and I was so I thought it was
just so cool you're doing and I was like
oh maybe I should do something like that
and then the minute I started to think
about it was like it's him you're not
you can't do that and so it just feels
like such an overwhelmingly daunting
sort of task to take on what did you
learn about starting and managing and
selling a business of that size I mean
listen it was a trial by fire like I
burned to the skin like I was a little
skeleton walkera actually I was I look
at some of my videos I'm like whoa you
were skeleton like you you did not look
good that or anorexic like it was not a
good look for me
because I was so stressed out I had so
you just you're I mean you're burning
the candle at both ends yeah I burned
out I was trying to be personality and
producer I'm writer and creator and
everything and it was just too much like
it was weighing too much it was a whole
company with a slate of things and I
wanted them
to look like TV and we never had the
bandwidth to do it covered and then we
weren't really supported in the way that
I kind of thought that we were going to
be because YouTube is so huge and we
weren't like prioritized over other
things and then you're just kind of
dumping really high-value content that
we put so much work into and then
someone like farting on camera is
getting 10 times the views and it's just
like I don't know what I'm doing yeah
that was great sorry you guys admire
what you're doing because not only were
you like an artist you were a
personality you were like alone I was
like so jealous I was like let's don't
do that having a bunch of employees
staring at you for leadership and like
why is this not working or like doing
payroll oh you know you gross it's so
grody yeah and then also just like I
don't know I mean I'm a perfectionist
and I loved my car I love my company but
I put everything into it would you go
back and do it again I would love to
redo it in a way that made it work
better I mean for me better like I think
what we did was amazing I still like
here's how I built it up I'm yeah I sold
it I think you know there were a lot of
mistakes along the way but I think we
did more good than bad I mean a lot of
innovative things that we did like the
twitch channel I'm the most proud of
like we built like a really really
strong twitch channel and started doing
things before everybody later in certain
areas like that really
I miss those days when web video was
like that same yes not really like that
anymore there's nothing out there like
all my friends are in that business are
unemployed or just in other field so it
just kind of cratered yeah it's sad
we're like the people who like were
specialized in victrolas we're like oh
yeah there's no there's no jobs for our
expertise anymore so that took me a
second to realize what you said I like a
Victrola Victrola is a music thing it's
an old okay that's the other thing too
is I'm anyone that has any music ability
any just natural sort of talent in that
world singing or playing an instrument I
am so jealous of because that's like a
superpower that I wish I could have
but that would be what you would be like
I if if tomorrow uh-huh somebody could
gift you one gift what would it be that
I could sing really well and also like
an Amazon gift card I would I just
literally thought of this because I've
had insomnia for two years since my baby
she broke me oh I think it's just like
this ain't my favorite TED talk about
why I should continue to not have a
child I mean I um I used to be a big
sleeper and she broke me like she's
sleeping now but I can't sleep I'm going
crazy oh man and I have gray hairs where
I was like where did those cover its
this baby I look at her I'm like this is
this is your fault but I think I used to
be my dream would be like learn
languages like in an instant because I
love I want to be that person who's
somebody's talking trash about in French
and I'd be like Lu you know I'd be able
to like say like drop it like it I know
your language but I would love to just
be able to close my eyes and sleep just
on a dime that would be my dream yeah
that's actually a great superpower to be
able to do yeah does it help anybody but
me it's it's selfish of course but you
know but then you are a better human
existing in the world's my face will be
better back yeah yeah it's better for
everybody it's better for everybody I
know that's what made me so mad any
ex-boyfriend that I had they all could
sleep anywhere anyways it was men who
could do that [ __ ] them I know was it
because they're just tough loved like no
because they can compartmentalize and
they don't worry about everything
all the time constantly [ __ ] idiots
bunch of idiots okay but not but knowing
that you have musical prowess what's
your like go-to karaoke song
you know that mr. mister we have to
bleep that out we don't the rights to
that bass podcast I used to use like in
one bar sure yeah but I think it's
always funnier to have just one long
bootleg yeah what the hell is she
talking about yep that way that song was
explicit you travel like crazy I'm sure
not as much anymore because you are in
the world of motherhood now yeah I feel
you're how many conventions do you think
you've gone to at this point what with
my baby
no just me 100 over like probably 100
yeah in my career I I mean I still do
them what's my baby oh and I travel I
travel with her all the time she's a
really good traveler that's great and uh
although I took her to Europe it was
like supposed to be my children here
yeah she's a baby what though okay now I
didn't know until I was in my 20s and
I'm like look at this life yeah she you
have to get you have you can yeah you
have to get a baby passport also in
order to fly with a baby even in your
lap they need a TSA card or you can't
use your TSA card what I got
I thought told by on the border like if
you'd bring this baby through here I
can't without a card I'm gonna take
yours and rip it up I literally I told
that oh I see it's a official like I was
trying to smuggle her in I was like she
doesn't know how to get a car she can't
pass the interview I had to fill it out
and they were like name the baby's last
four residents I'm like my womb baby did
she have to take like a photo yeah they
did I took him in for the interview in
there I was like are you gonna interview
her and they're like no she's a baby I'm
like duh but they did take that picture
she takes a really good picture I've
seen your Instagram she's great now
explored earlier I got a yeah I gotta
get some tips on how to take it better
like identification photo
it's a Tyra Banks thing you summize it
oh she has a whole article of like how
to prepare for your DMV voter that I use
every time I have to take a picture that
sounds perfect
yeah that that article exists no I just
look like bloated kato kaelin and all my
just red-faced and sweaty but you've
tried okay would you have a standout
memory from a convention good weird or
otherwise I mean I have a million of
them I think when my book I think I hope
devoted a whole chapter to them cuz
they're so like there's this part of my
work like I built my whole business on
on conventions yeah I literally I
started when I did Buffy yep and I was
like this is amazing people like me like
I'd like to see people in person liking
me and I'm really and I think that sort
of fuel made me like digital media when
I did it when I started doing it and
then when I did my web series I just
loved it so much I wouldn't show up to
any convention and just hang out
bookmarks that I had designed myself and
it was just like the characters were
hanging off the bookmark like I didn't
get the cut line so half of the money to
print these up again I would just stand
on the corner and people would just
literally crash it and right in front of
me and I'm like okay but I just love it
and just it just reminds you that
everything that we have in this world is
due to one person liking what you like
right and yeah and anything you do is
worth it if you can impact one other
person yeah whereas sometimes you get
the caught up and like how many numbers
do I have so many likes do I have how
many you know how much money I'm in oh
that's not really what counts like when
you're making art or creating it's how
you in effect yourself and then it's
sharing your worldview and making it
impact somebody else so it fits their
worldview right so that's what I love
about conventions I mean my highlight is
when someone tattoos their body with my
face that's always a good one
excuse you wait how many this has
happened more than once probably six or
seven times at least really good what
are you okay do you ever look at it and
go oh I wish she used a different photo
I mean that was a how as PMS saying
usually they use me in a codex outfit so
like I look like a badass and it's not
even my body and my boobs are much
bigger so it looks excellent excellent
I've had some fanart you know yeah like
there's some people's fan art who'd like
I don't look like that but listen some
of them make me look better so I'm gonna
make me worse I mean it's just really a
toss-up yeah I can't draw stick figures
so anything that anyone does is better
than me so it's very yeah I have fan art
is always very very
cool because I also have bad at drawing
so saying that someone's just like
artistically inclined I'm like that's
cool but I feel like we could learn how
to draw like some artists told me that
the other day at a party I was like I
can't draw she was like a storyboard
concept barbets for Marvel and she's
like she showed me her work I'm like I'm
like I can't do that she's like I could
show you I'm like really because I might
move here just real are you promising me
that if I relocate this hair and Cisco
you could teach me how to draw like you
because I might just give up everything
yeah that sounds great
we'll see what happens yeah I'll let you
know I'll leave the baby you want how to
draw you want her nope okay I mean I'm
sure you've had a lot of people come up
to you and it's very like overwhelming
and wonderful and sweet and exciting
have you had a fangirl moment or a
missed opportunity of someone that you
saw at an event a convention that you're
like oh god I don't
I can't even approach this scenario so
Mindy Kaling at do Parrs pancakes once
and I really felt like given our Twitter
Providence we might have connected okay
but then I passed it up because for like
two years before that I followed him for
six months and I kept adding her like
with funny things it was before the
verified checks really like roses to the
chop as Coe Patriots ya know so she
never acknowledged me and then I it was
almost like seeing her she was but I was
felt like betrayed by an ex texting you
why are you go at me I think there's
still time for you guys to create that
bond I think you should just
continuously at her it's no it's working
with me and you're right like we always
reinforce that the more persistent and
annoying especially in a group Twitter
when they're like yeah forty people
they're trying and then just continuous
like having a conversation I just want
to just go to their houses I'm just
kidding I don't okay we were talking
about Marie Kondo show oh yeah we were
okay you've just recently watched it and
are inspired by it
yeah I'm aspired and creeped out okay
like okay a she okay I have read the
book many years ago and I really love
the concept of her and she seems like a
lovely person who's a germaphobe doesn't
want to touch anybody or anybody's
things right yeah that's yep she does
and then also men are pigs in this show
like husbands are see I haven't seen an
episode yet oh okay you got to watch it
because boiler whoa okay well just on
the ones I only saw a couple I'm still
binging it but the first one especially
this guy you could just see on his face
that he thinks his wife is just a lazy
lazy person because he's working 60 to
70 hours a week okay really okay and
she's at home with the kids and then
literally this is what this is what was
so telling uh-huh because anybody who
doesn't have a child doesn't understand
how stressful and horrible and it's very
much harder on women than it is men
because just the baby is just so about
you at least my baby is just like
literally I leave the room and she's
like okay I'm here somebody want you
that much but kind of but anyway and so
Marie Kondo asked them do you both of
you work and she says well I teach class
a couple times a week
that's a part-time job yeah but mostly
I'm home with the two children who are
under four Wow and I'm like so you're
implying that that's not a work a job
right or B and your dinner you literally
have one and a half jobs lady yeah yeah
underselling how much work you put into
the world it's obvious his attitude is
that she's lazy oh it was such a dynamic
that I just wanted to go in his face but
I think that's kind of common because
you don't understand like late it is
work like it got an hourly wage with it
you know we pay people hourly wages to
take care of our children why would you
not consider that awful job even to
yourself right also Marie Kondo like I
wanted to see like a like a Container
Store hybrid where she literally brings
in things to organize things in a cool
manner yeah she brought like four
cardboard boxes and that's it right
she's like here this is what could help
you with your utensil drawer I'm like
this is just something that you got kids
somebody say something in this box and
you brought it for them to organize like
this is not even a thing nobody here
watch this clearly cuz this is so
universal right now drag her she's a
huge fan of the podcast you'll hear it
directly no I'm just saying that I just
expected her to be a little more
hands-on but your she doesn't even speak
English that very well so it's no
translator so I don't know why did you
say now I you sold me I really want to
see the show now I think you're gonna be
able to have a lot of yeah your child
discussion about it later in your life
the first book a couple years ago great
came back from an international trip and
then dumped all of my clothes in my
living room and then got sad and nothing
sparked joy literally just go it all
just got stressful and I was like I
don't even know what joy feels like now
I don't know and then I'm left with
clothes like this but I'm fascinated by
is there any other shows that you're
obsessed with right now I mean I love
the new Shira okay if anybody's watch
that right second it's incredible it's
so good and what else do I want I mean
I've been playing Assassin's Creed
Odyssey obsessively for the last three
months it's so good what's the best part
of it it's ancient Greece and it's like
you get to play this because I'm playing
the woman character Cassandra who's like
cut whoa he's cut she's got like
whenever she's like flexing her bicep
and has scars on I'm like you're sexy
and there's so much like romance and you
can romance option mostly women for you
know I guess so it's like this is
lesbian Greek Odyssey of sneaking around
stabbing people in the nads and just
making love to a I women and I'm just
like this is like a perfect game I don't
understand it
I'm okay I thought video games were very
different
I think I've been missing out to do yeah
it's really good it's really really good
I play competently now because my stream
I think they just love me but they were
like okay let's get you trained up
because I'm sick of you dying said
you're on easy mode why are you dying so
much so finally I've reached the point
where I'm semi-competent and I feel just
this sense of like oh my god I snuck in
there and murdered somebody stole the
heart and I got out without anybody
having a murder extra people I'm amazing
like it's my self-esteem is soaring
that's what a mother sounds like no
that's fantastic I'm such a terrible
gamer but I enjoy the camaraderie of the
discussion that happens during gaming do
you Poe yeah you mean like the smack
talk yeah I love getting asked to show
my tits kind of so I got you yeah I mean
I don't that's the whole mentality I
never understood about games I like it's
like it's not I mean I guess it's a
sport in some ways but then or people
can also game and be bad at it like it's
okay
yeah like we should all be okay with
that because it's a hobby like unless
you're making a living like there's two
grades of it now especially right I
don't know whatever let's just enjoy
what we wanted to joy we're all [ __ ]
dying right perspective guys all right
[Music]
- this episode nacho deep is brought to
you by P valve ever finish a workout
feeling sore too exhausted to function
not with P evolve they are the opposite
of a grueling high-impact painful
workout it's a completely science backed
method based on mastering precise
movements that activate hard to reach
muscles to create beautiful natural
muscle tone in less time using less
energy stream workouts ranging from 15
to 60 minutes with new classes each week
on the P valve app or online shape calls
P evolve the burn so good workout that
the Victoria's Secret Angels swear by
download the app watch tutorials and see
dozens of before and after pictures then
try P vol free for one month get 50% off
the premium P valve equipment kit at P
valve comm / grace this is the best deal
they have anywhere get a free trial for
one month and 50% off the premium peeve
off equipment kit at P valve comm /
grace that's P valve comm / grace ok
we're gonna get to some of your
questions if you guys have them in a
second we're gonna get into some Twitter
questions right now but then there were
a lot of them I was like well done but
before we do that I'm gonna ask you the
two questions asked every single cast of
this on the podcast the Streamy award
winning podcast now is there a Streamy
nominate a category for everyone it
don't know why don't know how but we
want it was I there to accept the award
no okay yeah so the questions I ask
every single guest that's on the podcast
is first of all who alive or dead would
you most wanna throw cold spaghetti act
cold spaghetti mm-hmm oh boy I mean
Marie Antoinette oh okay I think I say
Marie Kondo and I'd like we're back at
this I mean I know that was a very
immediate answer I don't know I've been
reading I was listening to this
revolutions podcast about the French
Revolution and she just came to mind cuz
she seemed like it kind of a [ __ ]
okay but you know royalty always it's
not like they're qualified right right
right right
just kind of there right even though I
love make it Marco for the record if I I
just literally it torments me that I
didn't audition enough to be able to
become friends with her now that she and
then be friends with her now Gina I'm
saying well yeah retrospectively I'm
like we could have really gotten along
but then in reality I'm not cool enough
to have been her friend I just wanted to
go to the Royal Wedding yeah cool as
heck Serena Williams was there I know
well her whole girl gang is just
incredible and I know a couple of them
like just so I felt like she steps away
yeah yeah it was better than Mindy
Kaling like I feel like we'd have a
better relationship with Mindy Kaling
there's a list there's this baggage yeah
Twitter history they have to delete okay
the other question ask every single
guest that's on the podcast is to tell
us your worst pants [ __ ] story or
close call but you can only use three
words or three small phrases so for
instance mine is college jogging front
lawn yeah mine is oh you have it
immediately yay
[Laughter]
c-section afterbirth curry
well that honestly eliminates like 20 of
the Twitter questions I had for you I
didn't I had a c-section so I thought I
was protected and then it was the hubris
it was the hubris involved cause that is
well after you give birth you become so
constipated hey did you know that no but
John Green is the first person that
educated me that women [ __ ] all over the
place when they give birth oh you didn't
know that that's why I don't want to do
a water tub birth because literally you
can poop on your baby like I think a lot
of people do this successfully without
pooping on their baby but there is the
risk that you poop on your baby and then
they have to go to the ER because they
have poop in their face okay right so if
you rename this podcast birth control
but anyway I took to MIT so basically
the thing you do not want to do is
become constipated so basically you take
colace stool softeners to make sure
everything's working down there okay
again I took too many Oh No yeah a
cautionary tale
all right very good you cannot really
want a story I love stories I feel like
you're really backing off like most
people are jovial and make it up like
that was a real poop story I think wait
you think I'm backing off of poop
stories I've heard so many three word
poop stories in the last of my life I
welcome it with open bowels okay here
are some Twitter questions let's see she
has played so many beloved characters
what would be the most epic script
written for her what would it be about I
at this point in my life would love to
play a like a spinster librarian who has
seven cats who gets transported to a
magical realm it becomes a sword fighter
and saves a whole nation with her sword
fighting ability okay it's that cool can
we do that I mean that was the wildly
specific I think we can't do that I feel
it's like it's like a hallmark movie
yeah that was more bloodshed that's
basically what I'd like to do let's make
it a Christmas one oh let's just make it
Christmas everyone loves a good
Christmas movie right there librarian
that becomes a hero yeah
of the sword okay someone said that
years ago I had a UCB improv class with
Felicia and always wanted to ask when
was the quote F it I'll make my own [ __ ]
moment I used to be UCB meeting the
place that I took three like 101 three
to four times but then I never quite
finished it so I just kept going back
until everyone was so young that it felt
like I wasn't appropriately in that
class again I think it was the other
place okay that's really cool um you
know I did it because I was in this a
self-help group with some other women
because we were all sad about our
careers and because they kept showing up
with like wins every week and I was just
playing World of Warcraft
all the time I felt like I should just
get off my ass and do something so I
wouldn't feel shame sure pancakes that
week so that's why I started writing a
script and then one of the women there
started doing videos when YouTube just
started she was like let's just make
this for the web because nobody cares
about your scripts and I think about
that whenever I've read a lot of scripts
and then you know managers or Hollywood
are like this is [ __ ] but I realized
they said that about the guilt too so
it's not like what I'm writing is
terrible it's just not right for them
right now
you know the guilt was not right for
them and I did something with that and I
made my whole career off of it yeah I
can't get down on my own abilities I can
just keep going and if I want to play
the game of pleasing them that's a whole
different kind of writing perhaps then
like the writing I want to do and I
guess that's the whole that's totally
valid though because it's not so much
solely based on skill set it's a lot
timing yeah a lot of it is timing a lot
of it is someone just in the right
moment saying oh yeah that appeals to me
and giving you a yes exactly
as long as just making stuff that either
you're catering to that or you're
catering to your own soul and you can't
get offended when you're rejected
because it's just not right for somebody
else right right and that's hard to do
because I'm like this piece of
brilliance what you you know like I feel
like you just get so right you're like
this is the most beautiful thing I ever
put on paper why are you such a fool but
that's how I end every pitch meeting I
have to really do that no you don't get
invited back so much you know if you
could be a celebrity's dog who's would
you be mmm I feel like that's a really
that's a hard one I feel like maybe Kim
Kardashian because I just feel like I
want to know what people like that live
like yeah I want to see firsthand them
shake their salads up do they shake
salads yeah that's like all they do they
sit and stare at each other on like
giant sofas and then they show you get
it I want to be with Oprah oh they're
gonna get some [ __ ] done
she's always gardening she's always
presenting avocados really her
instagrams fantastic
I don't follow any celebrities on his
surround you don't I only follow people
I know on Instagram I was gonna ask you
is there anyone that you like social
media stock at all other than Mindy
Kaling obviously I mean Mindy Kaling for
a time on Twitter there are a couple of
like I was giving you the information
about Britney Spears is gold mined of an
Instagram I know and I should follow her
I know I don't follow I for some reason
I started my Instagram like when it
first started and I'm just like I'm all
Twitter's like the public face of
Instagram it's only my so I follow very
few people on Instagram and when I do I
just start to become so demoralized for
some reason the pictures are more
demoralizing because I'm comparing
myself to other people especially their
thighs or like their hair it all comes
back to hair really wash your hair no in
my heart I want just like a pixie cut
but when I've done that in my past I
never work as an actress for like a year
and a half until it grows out to a bob
like for real well I will not work for a
year and a half until it is there and
it's like suddenly I'm good again like
it's so weird so like I can't do it
until I'm ready to just hang it all up
which could be soon I know we were
talking about this backstage you and I
are both barely hanging on right now
we're like we're I think we're like
getting into that midlife crisis we're
just like I know I think I might open
just owns like a fruit stand in Peru
yeah I keep saying what day am I gonna
run into the woods and make scarves out
of tree bark and sell it on Etsy it's a
viable back-up plan upcycle
so let's know what's the last thing that
happened that made you laugh so hard you
cry Wow who
god that's not really I don't know I
can't I mean it we can come back I got a
unicorn skin and Assassin's Creed the
other night and I literally was so happy
I started just like I guess I'd do that
for a little bit and I got a lot of
subscriptions out of that you just
figured out a new branding buddy like I
donate all that to charity but I don't
know what it was I mean it must be
something my kid did it's usually when
she's a smartass she's like no we're not
going to do that and she just started
putting words together yeah so when she
says something precocious like come on
man like she doesn't understand it
that's when I think I'm like oh she's
adorable like you see that's Jeremy
really yeah I kid that is that confident
but I'd be like all right sorry Jesus
okay okay I think we have we're coming
towards the end of the podcast but I
want to open up to you guys that are
here in the audience if anyone has any
questions don't feel shy or awkward but
maybe feel both of those things at the
same time and if you don't have any
questions I got a million more Twitter
questions asking about her [ __ ]
giving birth so anyway I didn't [ __ ]
when I gave birth I literally made an
appointment and they can't they cut me
open they took the baby out it was the
most humane thing ever like it literally
had to pick her birthday which was
stupid because I picked her I could have
picked like a cusp Earth Day between
Capricorn and Aquarius and I just picked
full Aquarius so does that is so she
sucks I just I feel like the odds are
less more steady anyway it's all
[ __ ] okay feel free
raise your have a microphone that will
come to you and then it will be a very
aggressive thing also if you don't be so
excited you guys there is like a
magician that I MAGIX know people are
like no not me not to it you also don't
have to have any questions you guys are
[ __ ] stoned it's San Francisco yeah
that's true all high on artisan coffee a
strand of weed go ahead oh we got one
hi
hey um I had a question in that how
important is it for you guys to make
your own creative content just for
yourself since you're already in
entertainment you know it could be it
like a weird type of thing but sure I
mean I for me it's it's it's a great
balance cuz I hate auditioning I hate
going in
especially for parts that I don't really
relate to but I feel obligated to go and
try to do because of the agents and
managers and that sort of thing so I
think it's always been very nice and has
in my past been very relieving to know
when I leave the audition I have the
internet there and I get the freedom to
make whatever I want without any
gatekeepers but it's about but now been
doing it for so long that I'm like oh
yeah you have new way to like this again
the maybe I'll go audition for a bunch
and then hate that it you have to do the
other thing like oh it wasn't so bad
business wasn't so bad why did you leave
bad that was I mean then they're like
then you were like should I go back to
that no because you've complained a lot
there but do you not complain anywhere
nowhere I really I think it's really
important for everybody to express their
creativity I feel like every I'm a big
believer and just everybody is creative
and needs to have their voice heard in
this world I think it's really important
it's the only chance you get to have
your voice heard like you everyone's
unique and we all have to see the world
in a different way and if we don't
express that then we'll never affect
anybody else who will then go on to
affect other people it's really our way
of just getting in the gumbo you know
and so whenever I feel really frustrated
I know that I love the fact that there's
always an outlet to do something let's a
little odd or a little small and
anything I've ever done even if it the
fancy stuff is what people admire like
supernatural or like any of the TV shows
that are done but the thing that I will
always cherish the most are the things
that I did that kind of defied people's
expectations and really represented me
in a pure way yeah and yeah I think
that's kind of what if that's where your
greatest sex and satisfaction is I think
that's where you should probably at
least always invest a little time yeah I
also think and tell me if you feel this
way it helps me feel less alone like if
I tell a story
if I express something that someone else
says I relate to that I get what you're
saying then it's like oh cool you know
we don't feel alone in this and maybe
this kind of like this creates new
connections in terms of like a just
personal experience yeah absolutely I
mean there's more universality
especially with things that make you
feel more alone like with my book a lot
of people responded to it because it was
I talked a lot about mental health and
depression and anxiety and all sorts of
things you have to overcome in order to
create and exist as a person and when
people say hey that really resonated
with me and it made me go do X like that
is very important and it also makes me
feel like in the process of sharing that
I'm discovering things about myself and
exposing them and knowing that you know
I am NOT alone in the experience that
I'm having so I think that's really
important and we can't grow from other
people unless others are sharing those I
think we'd find if everybody were as
open and transparent about their lives
that we'd all have way more in common
that we don't but a lot of people try to
manufacture image and brand and things
like that
from the outside or they get trapped in
something that people see them as and
then they aren't allowed to grow past
that you know I've had that in my career
a lot like I became like this to some
people and then when I did something
different they feel like but you're a
betrayed or something and we're we're
all constantly flowing through life and
changing and growing and if we're not
we're stunting ourselves and sometimes
you have to be willing to let go of
things in the past to move on to find
out what else you could be but it's hard
to look at that as a positive when
you're risking so much and moving on in
life so I just got really [ __ ] deep
[Laughter]
we've reached basically like the end of
the podcast didn't flee just gotta get
to the airport and I don't want to I'm
sorry I can't I would love to say hi to
anybody who came for me probably nobody
but um
I have to go to the airport immediately
so well we usually end the podcast with
a fortune cookie that is you know
specifically and uniquely designed for
our guests however my not bred for
survival director-producer was not able
to bring that with him give me some
lotto ticket numbers and then somebody
can run those and if they win they can
get me half okay yeah here we go
six nine six nine
that's it's a winner every time that's
for people just giving each other oral
sex is that what happens on the weekends
felicia where what can people be excited
about what are you up to
what can you talk about and where can
people find you if they don't already
know okay
one you can watch me streaming on twitch
twitch TV slash Felicia Day I do it
every Saturday night so if you if you're
like me come hang up sometimes on
fridays i also have my own podcast
called felicitations is every two weeks
it's very loose not like this or actual
efforts but into it but come on over I'm
doing a new podcast it's an improv
science-fiction process it's really
funny it's as Colton Brown and Janet
Varney and Steve Berg and we're
traveling through space as incompetent
people it's called voyage to the stars
and that's out next month and you can
watch me on Mystery Science Theater on
Netflix I am in the new season and
hopefully we have another season I don't
know maybe come in hopefully but the
last one is really good so please watch
it that's awesome thank you so much for
being here
making time and thank you guys so much
for being here deep deep deep deep this
episode of not too deep was brought to
you by Merc re Macari is the selling app
that makes it fast and easy to sell
almost anything just take a few pics add
a description and boom your item is
listed with buyers in all 50 states
stuff really cells and everything ships
easily so there are never any awkward
meetups you can find mark re on the App
Store's
or Elmer CARICOM that's mark re M er CA
RI this episode of nuts deep was brought
to you by P vulva a completely science
backed workout method based on mastering
precise movements to create beautiful
muscle tone in less time using less
energy download the app
watch tutorials and see dozens of before
and after pictures then tripe evolve
free for one month and get 50% off the
premium P valve equipment kit at
people.com slash grace this is the best
deal they have anywhere get a free trial
for one month and 50% off the premium P
valve equipment kit at people.com such
grace P valve calm such grace
[Music]